[Music]
what we're seeing in the last 10 years
certainly are large companies failing
companies like Kodak companies like
blockbuster companies like Sears and if
you step back and think about it it's
not obvious why that should be and when
you ask people why that's so they
typically say well they're being
disrupted but disrupted by what
disruption really means the emergence of
a new set of competitors a different way
of doing business a different technology
that allows you to do business in
different ways but the interesting thing
is that the pace of change the pace of
disruption is actually increasing and in
the face of that disruption those
changes what we're seeing are big
companies failing
there are three very separate
disciplines that they have to be good at
if they're going to be successful at
dealing with disruption they have to
have a process a discipline for
developing new ideas what we call
ideation they have to figure out which
of those ideas are likely to be
successful as a business what we refer
to as incubation and then the third
discipline is that they have to once
they have a an idea that looks like it
could be successful they have to have a
set of processes that ensure that that
new business gets the assets and
capabilities they need to grow and
here's the problem some companies are
pretty good at incubation they're
perfectly willing to spend money to come
up with new ideas the problem comes when
these businesses begin to scale and it
takes serious resources when that
happens suddenly these senior executives
who are all in favor of innovation
suddenly realize that to develop new
businesses they may in fact have to
sacrifice some short-term profits that's
when many CEOs suddenly step back and
say maybe not
let's focus just for a second on Amazon
Amazon was founded in 1994 in 25 years
they have gone from zero revenues to two
hundred and thirty billion dollars with
more than six hundred thousand employees
they compete in businesses as diverse as
online shopping but they also produce
television shows they have Amazon Web
Services which is the largest cloud
provider in the u.s. they are in a
variety of different businesses how have
they done that they've done it by having
very careful processes for ideation
incubation and scaling they have a
process which they call the PR FAQ FAQ
process this is a process that
encourages people throughout the
organization to come up with ideas for
new businesses if the idea is deemed to
have potential then they immediately
move into an incubation phase they form
small teams these teams are responsible
for coming up with a minimal Viable
Product to put in front of a customer if
that idea turns out to look potentially
successful they immediately move into a
scaling mode where they provide
resources for it they escalate it they
get senior management attention one of
the things Bezos says is that most
companies don't really do experiments
they don't take the big risks what Bezos
says if you place big bets just a couple
of those big bets succeeding will pay
for all the small failures the nice
thing about companies like Amazon and
Walmart and some of these other
companies is that they do these things
in in very rapid pace that is they don't
take forever to decide whether a new
idea is potentially valuable or not the
problem is that in big exploit
organizations the processes are
typically very measured very slow and
that often times can kill innovation so
when you do these things you need to do
these processes rapidly
this is really a leadership issue when
we look at companies that have failed
have been disrupted it's not because of
technology they fail because they didn't
have leaders who could play multiple
games simultaneously almost all
companies today are really interested in
innovation but the thing that they often
are not sophisticated enough at is
making this distinction that we've been
talking about between ideation
incubation and scaling the best of these
companies have managers who understand
that it takes all three of these
disciplines
[Music]
you